[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour ce
nouveau vip nous recevons aujourd'hui
une personnalité des médias alors ce
n'est pas franck ferrand ce n'est pas
ces feux stéphane bern ce n'est pas
patrice carmouze car ils sont déjà venus
c'est david abiker david abiker bonjour
bonjour merci d'être sur notre plateau
tv 78 alors vous êtes ici car quand on
observe bien votre compte du geek
instagram
on retrouve des lieux qui sont un peu
yvelinois alors est ce que c'est votre
chien ici présents obi-wan qu'on en a eu
marre du bois de boulogne et qui a
demandé à agrandir son territoire
c'est ça l'idée et si vous voulez le
bois de boulogne on faisait toujours le
même parcours moi j'habite à paris mais
au bois de boulogne et c'était toujours
le même parcours le bois de boulogne et
du glace il faut dire les choses il est
crado et ma foi les arbres sont un
peuple et au bois de boulogne quand vous
faites le bois de boulogne l'hiver c'est
quand même
alors bon sens et contenter et puis j'ai
découvert le parc du château de
versailles
voilà vous allez au parc du château de
versailles à personne et puis j'ai des
attaches dans les yvelines
g j'ai habité des maisons du côté de
houdan du côté de granby et donc la
bayanne bouyer il ya de l'espace
alors non seulement il ya de l'espace
donc le chien est content mais il ya
surtout des bonnes tables aussi on peut
faire des bonds gueule seriez picchio
fait je suis gourmand quoi mais c'est
surtout que donc les yvelines c'est la
campagne tout près de paris c'est bon
gueuleton et la promenade digestive
après ou avant
je pense que les jeux se mérite c'est
pour l'appétit vient d'ouvrir l'appétit
pour manger plus cela et après se
balader pour éliminer balader marché
avant après ou faire la sieste après
tout dépend tout
je veux dire que j'ai découvert ce
département des yvelines avec beaucoup
de gourmandise et le déclic ça a été
vraiment le château de versailles le
château je l'avais visiter enfants quand
j'étais petit mais le parc je
soupçonnais pas que en plus moi j'ai des
horaires un peu bizarre donc oui si vous
allez au parc de versailles à 10 heures
lundi matin ou à 14 heures à mercredi
après midi
il n'y a personne bien des mamans oui
mais en fait les gens les gens restent
autour du parcours les gens restent
autour du bassin mais vous pouvez
quasiment marché sans rencontrer
personne est sûre dans le partage est
très sauvage et c'est merveilleux on est
d'accord bombasse à nouveau la joie de
votre visite tard et je suis resté dix
alors vous j'ai l'impression que vous
avez eu deux vies alors une première vie
vous avez travaillé comme responsable du
pôle pédagogique à sciences po à la
monnaie par et je veux le dire dans le
désert ce l'effet d'autres consultants
là j'ai une vie d'entreprise dj une vie
d'entreprise ce qui ce qui est assez
rare dans le journalisme dire que les
journalistes aujourd'hui ils y sont
formés à 20 ans où ils sortent à 22 ans
23 ans de l'école ils font des stages et
ils font tout leur carrière dans le
journalisme comme un médecin fret ou de
la médecine mois il se trouve que j'ai
eu des opportunités et des accidents de
parcours qui ont fait que j'ai d'abord
eu 15 ans ou 20 ans de vie d'entreprise
et puis ensuite il ya eu arrêt sur image
et le france inter et puis elle a
redonné j'ai basculé de l'autre côté
voilà maintenant vous êtes un homme de
médias
on vous voit à la télévision vous avez
travaillé sur plusieurs chaînes venus de
france 5
paris première radio france inter europe
1 france info
on peut pas tout citer tellement vous
avez fait chose on va revenir à l'actu
sur tout et qu'est ce que j'ai oublié
près ceci m'a dit claire j'ai ku des
revues plus sérieuse de faim aujourd'hui
avait vu il ya une revue qui s'appelle
management voilà plus de deux textes qui
s'appelle 01net
quelques ont participé j'ai participé en
fait aujourd'hui vous écrivez dans un
magazine vous savez que la presse va pas
toujours très bien mais si vous m'aidez
vos articles sur les réseaux sociaux là
vous avez quasiment autant de lecteurs
que dans un journal classique d'accord
et donc donc je partage tout ce que
j'écris sur les réseaux sociaux
d'accord alors au niveau de la
télévision vous êtes sur canal + l'info
du vrai le mag c'est à 18h30 tous les
jours vous êtes le complice dix
événements 17h45 à 17h45 et ensuite ya
effectivement l'info du vin avec yves
calvi à 18h30 mais vous vous êtes
jusqu'à quelle alors même que ce 17h45 à
18h30 et ensuite qu'elle vit arriver
ensuite mouloud achour
oui ren lac hikma la géniale clic et
dites moi alors vous vous êtes un
permanent de la bande
vous êtes moi j'y suis tous les jours
quand on dit qu'on doit on dit qu'on
comme nîmes avec avec isabelle moreau
mais enfin c'est quand même l'animatrice
et isabelle moret et moi je suis je suis
un peu son son garnements de services
d'accor est au vigneau voilà un petit
peu d'accord ok donc ça c'est la
télévision la radio actuellement alors
il ya deux choses
vous êtes le week end l'après-midi sur
radio classique de 16 à 19 heures voilà
alors c'est quoi le principe de cette
émission ça s'appelle votre week end
radio classique et en fait c'est trois
heures d'animations musicales donc il
faut une programmation x 3 m la 2e
classique on a des programmateurs
extraordinaire comme eric taver et
francis gruzelle et donc ces gens là
nous concocte un menu musical on peut
leur demander des choses moi je demande
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux aux gens
de manger voilà donc les gets interagir
cuillère ouais je le redis écrivez-moi
écrivez moi à une souvenirs associés à
une musique ou une musique à sociale et
donc ces trois heures de musique
classique que samedi trois heures le
dimanche et donc il faut il faut amener
tout ça sans être trop bavard déjà
choisissez donc les souvenirs et les
morts je vous lis des choses que je les
lisais ouais je lis les lie à leur tête
travail de sélection oui mais bon ça va
on met un texte d'auditeurs par tranche
horaire un ou deux maximum
et puis c'est des petits textes et des
petits moments mais vous n'imaginez pas
à quel point les gens écoutent la
musique dans leur voiture ou à quel
point c'était associés à leurs souvenirs
d'enfant oui on a beaucoup de mélomanes
aussi puiss à la musique classique
renvoi des souvenirs tiens je me
souviens mon père ou mon oncle ma mère
me faisait écouter ceux ci où il y avait
une pochette de disque dans la
discothèque et ça m'a marqué il ya mille
façons de se souvenir de la musique
classique d'accord alors le matin fait
que 30 alors le magasin ouais d'accord
je me lève 1 4 me c'est dur à quelle
heure parce que vous faites la revue de
presse ouais
j'arrive à 5 heures voilà donc
j'arrivais à 5h je lis les journaux il
ya les titres à 7h25 donc là c'est une
minute pour dire la libé ceci macha le
monde le figaro
et puis à 8h30 une revue de presque
complète
voilà ça c'est toute l'équipe vous êtes
dans la matinale de guillaume durand
vous êtes vous êtes une aventure euros
par an et voilà les rejoint radio
classique comme franck lérand d'ailleurs
exactement et laurence ferrari aussi est
alors dites moi comment on fait pour
faire une revue de presse anp si vous
avez un parti pris c'est forcément
subjectif
en fait vu presse en fait pour moi et
après 1 an d'expérience à europe 1 et un
an de presque 1 an d'expérience à radio
classique
la revue de presse je crois qu'à un
moment donné vous vous laisser séduire
par une idée par un fait par quelque
chose et c'est ça qui va éclairer votre
votre lanterne pour assembler des
articles qui vont vous permettre de
parler de plusieurs choses mais en fait
avec une idée fixe par exemple ce matin
pour moi c'était l'imaginaire c'est l
imaginaire yaris est venu parce qu'en
fait il ya un magazine qui a titré
heures un hors série ça s'appelle la
magazine s'appelle ce seul charles terre
ils ont titré leur magazine le réveil de
l'imaginaire et donc à partir de ça je
me suis dit mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya de
qu'elle est pourquoi il ya une prime à
l'imaginaire en ce moment et une prime
ali g à l'imaginaire parce qu'on pense
que la fin du monde est proche il ya une
prime à l'imaginaire parce qu'on invente
des fausses nouvelles
il ya une prix
à l'imaginaire parce qu'on a faim on
veut inventer un autre monde parce qu'il
ya des utopies et je me suis dit c'est
pas si bête est dans l'actu ensuite on
va piocher des shows à chaque fois
chaque matin vous prenez un angle oui je
me sens soudain chose mais à ce point
c'est quelque chose m'inspire hier par
exemple je suis plus que j'ai fait je
sais pas ce que j'ai en plus la dernière
c'est en oublie on ne serait pas le
coureur il y avait le corona virus était
plus c'était bien joué je sais plus ce
que c'était le coronavirus était juste
et plus jubilait c'est comme ça que ça
marche
une actu chasse l'autre on a une mémoire
de poisson rouge et or c'est très beau
coup voilà et j'imagine que le vendredi
est un peu plus de pression dont ça ça
ça met en jeu peut-être les ventes de
différents magazines chics et puma
d'oeil à aucune pression le vendredi au
contraire parce que si vous voulez
aujourd'hui la revue de presse qui vous
l'a fait vraiment c'est ça vous avez
votre téléphone vous mettez vos alertes
sur votre smartphone et vous avez toute
la revue de presse que vous voulez tous
les vrais alors j'ai les autres élevages
et les journaux en vrai mais je les ai
aussi sur mon smartphone et je partage
sur les réseaux sociaux des couvertures
que j'ai attrapé sur les sites
numériques
mais en vérité le vendredi le vendredi
je fais un peu ce que je veux je me dis
il tient ces vendredi on est déjà un peu
en week end
donc j'essaye d'envoyer les gens vers
des choses un peu différentes last et
l'imaginaire ouais cela c'était l'egypte
l'imaginaire l'année la semaine dernière
j'aurais pu faire je sais pas tiens on
va vous parler que des bonnes nouvelles
est là on va aller chercher dans les
hebdos des choses qui sont sympas on va
vous parler de bouffe on va vous
l'ambiance de week-end
oui c'est bien parce qu'en plus ce mois
le vendredi je m'arrête à 9 heures j'ai
pu la télé j'ai pas d'enregistrement le
vendredi est donc pour moi le vendredi à
9 heures c'est direction les yvelines
dans l'obscurité un jeu m'a dit si c'est
le bonheur le vendredi et c'est vraiment
les yvelines en ligne débat merci alors
d'état doit être arrêté sur la route
fini le chien alors ce fameux chien
obi-wan ya un sur les réseaux sociaux on
voit beaucoup ce chien ou de ma vie
privée que je parte d'accord et alors
qu'est ce que c'est que cette fameuse
ligue canine des travailleurs c'est venu
d'une d'une jeune femme
il s'appelle isabelle qui un jour sur
linked in m'a dit mais à force de
montrer votre chien est de parler des
bienfaits du chien dans les open space
et au bureau il faut créer la ligue
canine des travailleurs donc elle m'a
donné le titre
quelqu'un a fait le logo quelqu'un
d'autre à l'aise aussi fait le logo est
alors le logo on l'a amélioré parce que
je les redonner à ma fille je dis
faudra-t-il est grave et donc elle m'a
fait ce logo qui représente mon chien
précédent charlie mort qui représente un
peu tous les chiens oui et en fait c'est
l'idée de d'encourager les gens à faire
un maximum de choses avec leurs animaux
parce qu'en fait ça crée des ponts entre
les gens a justement est-ce que c'est
pas un peu une façon de rétablir l
équilibre entre les réseaux sociaux les
écrans qui nous isole tous et le chien
qui permettent par les anars verte
qu'ils commencent à parler aux siens
mais le chien ce sont ces réseaux ont
par le haut mais ben oui le chien vous
le caresser comme un téléphone il vous
emmène dans le réseau social de tous les
propriétaires de chiens déjà et puis il
fait en sorte c'est que les gens vous
parlent avec le chien en vrai dans la
rue en fait ils caressent le chien et
vous pensez que c'est des lay que pour
vous et quand quelqu'un est gentil avec
mon chien je pense qu'il est gentil avec
moi mais en fait il est y passent juste
un bon moment avec mon chien mais moi je
passe un bon moment parce que les gens
sont détendus et que vous n'avez pas
besoin que le chien a des qualités qui
sont extraits bien bien utile à l'humain
et qui sont un peu oubliés je veux
parler de la fidélité la bienveillance
parler d'un amour et le chien c'est
vraiment l'amour et la fidélité
inconditionnelle le chien c'est aussi se
contenter de ce qu'il a c'est
intéressant on dit les animaux sont des
bêtes et les humains sont intelligents
mais quand vous regardez un chien dans
la forêt ou quand vous regardez vivre un
chien vous apercevez que le chien il
fait il avec l'intelligence qu'il a il
optimise qui va bien renifler il va bien
manger il va bien s'amuser il va bien
dormir et finalement il va exploiter
toute son intelligence au service de ses
besoins et nous en a trop
d'intelligences qu'on n'exploite pas
suffisamment pour être en phase avec
notre environnement
donc on peut prendre exemple sur les
chiens ou sur les bêtes
pour voir à quel point bas ils sont
intelligents puisque avec une
intelligence bien moindre que celle des
hommes
il arrive à exploiter leur environnement
plus intelligemment secret et une joie
de vivre et un beau dessus à bien le
chien cjrc des attentats à la joie c'est
ce que vous dites quand on râle
d'attentats justement voir un clin
d'oeil à à charlie votre premier chien
nous avons juste après le 10 janvier
ouais je les avais charlie à cause des
attentats sur son temps ouais et là on
vous voit franco français sont
impopulaires
j'aime bien me déguiser et là j'allais
en réveillant déguisé ma femme me prend
en photo dans le métro j'étais avec
charlie est on allé une soirée déguisée
et j'avais inventé ce personnage de
franck françois c'est à dire une espèce
de chanteur un peu ringard offre et
ouais ouais
et donc c'est l'occasion de mettre des
doutes sur les réseaux sociaux
ça fait longtemps que je n'ai pas sortir
enfin soit à lui j'ai les jambes jeu
saccagé
je sais plus j'ai mis sa perruque iphone
asie vous à péage en effet être vous
mais bon on peut adhérer ses deux filles
canine de travailler c'est une adhésion
gratuite et universelle qui veut prendre
le logo et le mais sur son fond d'écran
en fait un mug fait des badges voilà il
ya des badges on peut tout faire avec le
logo sofer du commerce d'accord voilà
ok c'est comme les gilet jaune et gilet
jaune c'est pas une association c'est
pas un mouvement tout le monde peut
avoir un gilet jaune
tout le monde peut être membre de
l'amicale et les travailleurs sans aucun
papier ni rien à papier rien gmail a
déposé les statuts c'est horrible je
veux le faire piquer en c4 mais on
retient que c'est vous oui on retiendra
cette émission ce sera la preuve voilà
exactement david abiker bon week end
merci à vous même ce week end la
compagnie a très vite parce que vous
écrivez aussi peut-être que pourriez
créer un livre serait l'occasion de vous
recevoir arriver ça fait disait que ça
allait d un bouquin je suis droit chez
un gros fainéant ce même mois au fait
beaucoup de choses voilà ouais merci à
treize finales merci au revoir à tous
il